Brother!
It`s been too long (YEP)
Hey, how's it going bros?
Aaaa
My Name is PewDiePie!
I've been scavenging the INTERNET (rly poods?)
and I found this game (yay)
that i have never seen anyone play before :O
*FREAKS OUT*
EHEHEH
It's a joke. (srsly)
everyone has played this game
It's an old classic
It's a fine wine
A fine wine of video games
i'm talkin' of course is facade
*dat moosic doe*
*wat*
Mah name'a JEFF
MAH NAME'A JEFF!!
If you haven't played this game before
you are supposed to
save the relation of trip and grace
*knock knock knock*
Penny!
PENNY
PEHNEEY
PEHNEYY
JEFF!
MAH NAME'EH JEFF
*dat face* UHH
OOOOOOOOOOOOO
eheh i forgot how tidy is arse is
oh man
jeff has problem walking trips ass my
god oh my god i 8 ball i remember this
will i get trips ass tonight who knows
that is the chance Barris a god there is
a chance okay the goal here is to break
them up i will go for Josh there's that
bitch I would go for trip song stay away
hi how are you Oh stay away stay away
from me demon child oh no and make
yourself at home okay fine to stay away
I'm protected by their rainbow dildo the
sculptures nope I used to be so into
collect hawk Connie you're injured Hawks
hey you love your sculpt here so much
i'm not even allowed to touch them trick
your poker buddies used them as ashtrays
Oh anyhow Jeff Jeff Jeff I like to look
at tricks ass my name is jeff i'll let
you flirt with me just one time cuz
we're friends hey come here says come
here you're hugging me how nice of you
you like that you like that great
friend after so long I want to be great
Franklin there's a problem Jeff yeah
yeah that's my name nothing's wrong
everything's fine Wow seeing you again
love say my name is a wonderful times we
all used to have in the sexy done
dungeon oh I think we're gonna need it
Hey look at their fucking face exec okay
Jeff yes what does this picture make you
think Oh trip don't pour a friend on the
spot like that in a word what does this
say to you never do my name is one word
okay yeah romance ah it says romance god
damn it I always get it wrong great can
you go away yeah JK grace is ugly oh oh
oh someone get that boat where did I put
it is buck how can you Jeff know my name
at Jeff oh it's my dad individually I'm
not saying anything it's still ringing
okay he's being annoying as usual just
just hang it up hello give me give me a
hug
well I was awkward are you guys not
going to say anything you're just Jeff
how about dies that's a good
conversation starter okay hi Rick do you
do squats
okay there's no way to communicate Jeff
okay all right I get it you guys don't
want me here fine I don't care I don't
care anymore I just walked through the
door good game good game what the fuck
happened all right why don't we try
another name see if that's more
productive car fucking cause that really
a name car what up y'all that's a cool
name it's not a name fucking League of
Legends character name it 12 I'm 12 yes
I am penny penny penny penny gah bazinga
fancies entry pass is it big sure thing
told you confirmed trips ass confirmed
ah here hey Paul just tripped love me oh
my god ha hi how are you i am so happy
to see you after so long brother it's
been too long cowan's hard drives a
martini sound how does oh yeah you are
near the kind of person in itself help
and stare god I don't shake em okay I'm
just gonna go my god what are you doing
it right now oh well maybe you'd like
some juice or move a Brita here haha ok
and makes me remember the little times
we all used to have trap hop oh well
thanks wait that's not a compliment huh
you always have such nice things to say
he's the nice nips
oh I'm kissing now I'm kissing j/k I'm
getting right ha that's it you've got a
fucking Jamison gosh you can expect to
clean up no you know let me stay at we
can put up with a lot but we have our
limits you know let me in let kind I'm
so bad at this game ah it's been too
long look I have friends ha look at all
my friends hi how are you i am so happy
to see you after so long yeah how are
you doing I just asked him that well i'm
asking him to hey um wait you think
Maria that's right Maria haha oh you're
you're quite the Kidder tonight trip
hahaha yeah eating maria never afraid to
say anything that pops into your mind
wait you think I'm cheating on grace yes
with me he looks so happy about it yes
you uh you're really you're
cheating yeah that's my boy hey cartel
see how witty nice Kyle no so good on a
fake how do I play there's only so much
you can expect you know that's Christ
Jeff are you are you leaving the room
anyway where's your bed can't remember
what we were talking about oh yeah i
line my very very difficult to each his
grind dad the whole right what do you
think
yeah Jeff what do you say oh my god oh
my god is no scary this game is a
fucking horror game I swear to God Jesus
no no I really think we have this won't
trust me trust me you're look at how
beautiful maybe you'd like some juice or
mineral water yeah no we need to open
this all have our friend is here we're
going to enjoy ourselves that's all
there is to it I've been dying to try
this Bordeaux for a long time it's a
perfect anniversary wine is it fuck you
bitch shut the fuck up this bag the fuck
up and I forgot you sometimes I feel
like our whole marriage is just for show
I don't know what you really feel Oh
where's yeah are you doing can you
believe it here I know it's crazy what I
what are you saying to me god damn Italy
I try to reach out to you I try to be
romantic with you but you're cold and
distant I do I really try yeah what I'm
going to ask you something grace okay
great let me ask all right okay I'm
ready finally tell me what do you want
what do you want yes or no okay in a
marriage shouldn't one person try to
make their spouse a better person even
if they don't want it what is this tough
one it's a really tough one um Jeff my
name is Jeff you know I've never wanted
anyone but you no no no burn she earned
bed I mean no Jeff you wanted me I know
yeah I've had enough of this bullshit
Jeff I know what you're trying to hint
at about me what about what yeah our
marriage you're gay and you want to run
it where you want the truth huh yes yes
the truth please great give me the truth
do you want Josh yeah i think the
attention to what you've been saying
tonight thank you finally pushing me
I have been because I know under I
really might friend or not well now your
friend I'm your love I ask you this yes
or no okay really think that flirting
with me praising grace flirting with
grace and worst of all seeing that
letter with ever-loving success has to
realize something about myself from all
is what you get in tonight's supposed to
add up some out of something
my name is Jeff